le couple c'est la tendresse l'amour
partagé
on rêve d'avoir des enfants on s'imagine
un futur plein de rires et de câlins et
puis un jour on est sur le terrain et là
ça se passe pas toujours exactement
comme ça dans le couple comme avec nos
enfants
il nous arrive de partir en vrille
parfois nous avons des réactions
démesurées
jamais je n'aurais imaginé éprouvée à
l'intérieur de moi de tels impulsion de
violence envers les personnes que j'aime
le plus au monde
je supplie côté rappeuse est depuis
toujours je cherche à comprendre les
motivations de nos comportements
pourquoi les adultes se comporte de
manière si exagéré et pourquoi les
enfants ne font ils pas tout simplement
ce que nous leur demandons pour répondre
à ces questions
j'ai étudié les scientifiques tout le
monde aujourd'hui parle de stress c'est
le professeur hand ce chéquier qui a
introduit ce concept dans les années 50
pour décrire la réaction d'adaptation de
l'organisme face à toute stimulation
le stress est donc une réaction
d'adaptation pour assurer notre survie
dans notre cerveau une petite glande
veille
l'amygdale depuis la nuit des temps
au moindre danger elle déclenche
l'alarmé dans l'organisme
adrénaline cortisol notre corps est
mobilisé pour combattre ou fuir et si je
ne peux ni combattre ni fuir
je me mobilise je fais le mort mon corps
et insensibiliser un danger mais aussi
une frustration une contrainte déclenché
le stress chez les petits ou chez les
plus grands mesurons que le stress est
une réaction
zik adrénaline cortisol dans mon corps
accélération cardiaque mobilisation
musculaire la mâchoire avance nous avons
envie de taper lancer dans nos bras nos
jambes ont envie de trépigner de courir
nous adultes avons la capacité de
maîtriser cette réaction de stress même
si c'est pas toujours facile quand notre
conjoint laisse traîner ses chaussettes
ou un petit enfant de 2 ans ne veut pas
mettre ses bottes mais lee le cerveau du
petit enfant ne leur permet pas encore
de pouvoir réguler ce stress quand notre
enfant déborde
nous entendons par tous il faut lui
poser des limites et nous nous engageons
un rapport de force
quitte à y perdre nos forces parce que
c'est ce qui se passe à lutter pour être
le plus fort tout le monde perd parfois
nous croyons voir réussi à ramener un
enfant à la raison parce qu'il s'arrête
il n'est pas devenu singes il s'est
juste immobilisé par réflexe de stress
mettre des limites
c'est comme mettre un couvercle sur du
lait qui bout le lait déborde quand même
il faut tenir solidement et il va
falloir nettoyer tout autour pas
question non plus de juste regarder le
lait déborder sans rien faire ici
j'éteignais le gaz
je vais vous raconter comment un jour ma
mère a su éteindre le garage alors que
j'avais débordés j'avais 13 ans et j'ai
donné une gifle à ma mère oui j'ai donné
une gifle à ma mère
ce n'était pas un geste vraiment
volontaire et elle l'a compris bien sûr
sur l'instant elle m'a retourné la gifle
mais après cette réaction réflexe elle
est venue me parler me faire parler
elle savait que lorsqu'un enfant va chez
le médecin se faire faire une piqûre
quand il rentre à la maison il n'a de
cesse que de faire des piqûres à tout le
monde
il se met du bon côté de la seringue
ma mère a cherché d'où venait cette
gifle je revenais de chez une amie et
j'ai raconté à ma mère la scène qui
m'avait choqué mon ami s'était disputé
violemment avec sa mère qui lui avait
donné une gifle et mon ami lui avait
retourné la gifle j'étais figé je ne
comprenais pas je suis rentré chez moi
comme une automate incapable de penser
de sentir de parler de contraindre mène
ce qui se passait à l'intérieur de moi
jusqu'à ce que je vois ma mère à ce
moment là retrouvant ma maman ma
sécurité
c'est comme si mon corps avait reçu la
permission de sortir de l'immobilisation
et là les tensions refoulés depuis la
scène des gifles 1 chez mon ami revenez
à la surface adrénaline cortisol mon
corps se réveillait mobilisation
musculaire je commençais à me sentir de
plus en plus énervé étendue comme j'ai
prouvé cette agressivité
depuis que j'avais vu ma mère je lui en
ai attribué la cause je me suis
embrouillé avec elle pour des vétilles
et là mon corps a fait quelque chose qui
m'a stupéfiée il a reproduit la gifle
mon cerveau n'arrivant pas à trouver les
mots pour expliquer à ma mère a guidé
mon corps pour qu'il montre à ma mère la
gifle qui m'avait fait mal pour qu'elle
m'aide et elle m'a aidé elle m'a aidé à
mettre des mots sur mes émotions
elle m'a aidée à éteindre le gaz sous le
lait qui bouillait à l'intérieur de moi
je pouvais avoir confiance en elle une
autre situation dans la rue une mère et
son enfant l'enfant en marche dans la
rue tranquillement et il ya de la
circulation
la mère s'énerve il dit peu moins mais
immédiatement l'enfant esquive la main
de sa mère s'éloigne pour l'enfant
esquivez n'est pas une décision
consciente
c'est une réaction automatique de stress
notre stress stress nos enfants et
déclenché une réaction biologique dans
leur cerveau qui débranchent les couches
supérieures de leur cerveau parfois nous
demandons un enfant qui déborde de
réfléchir à son comportement avec une
efficacité toute relative
évidemment puisque son cerveau n'est
plus branché
comment faire pour rebrancher
reconnecter le cerveau de nos enfants
comment faire pour désactiver le circuit
du stress nous avons convoqué dame
ocytocine l'ocytocine l'hormone de
l'amour de la relation l'hormone 1 qui
permet de calmer ce stress touché un
enfant le regarder avec tendresse
communiqué chaleureusement avec lui lui
permet de retrouver tout son cerveau et
de gérer le stress
c'est ce qu'a fait ma mère avec moi mais
est ce que ça ne va pas récompenser un
comportement inacceptable diraient
certains
la plupart d'entre nous avons appris à
considérer l'amour comme une récompense
les neurosciences ont montré que
manifester notre amour à nos enfants
déclenché une sécrétion d'ocytocine
multiplie le nombre de récepteurs a
aussitôt signe dans le cerveau diminue
les hormones de stress augmente
l'immunité et développe les circuits
neuronaux dans le cerveau préfrontal le
cerveau préfrontal celui qui permet
l'empathie la maîtrise de soi celui qui
permet la régulation émotionnelle
l'anticipation la capacité de comprendre
et identifier l'impact de nos actes la
responsabilité c'est ce cerveau là que
nous voulons développer chez nos enfants
grâce à un geste un sourire une marque
d'attention
nous préparons nos enfants au bonheur
nous les équipes ont littéralement pour
faire face au stress
nous leur permettons de savoir ne pas
surréagir de ne pas sur-réagir plus tard
quand ils auront eux mêmes des enfants
l'amour c'est du carburant pour réguler
le stress concrètement j'ai envie de
partager avec vous une petite technique
que nous avons mise au point
mon compagnon et moi je vous raconte la
situation
il est 19 heures j'ai passé la journée
avec les enfants il est un peu tard
ray il rentre en ayant oublié la course
que je lui avais demandé de faire là je
crise
mon amoureux se sent coupable
ils s'installent devant la télévision ou
bien par la pharmacie c'est normal un
homme n'a pas le droit de faire mal à
une femme il ne veut pas combattre il
fuit mais s'il ressort pour faire la
course que je lui ai demandé ça ne me va
pas du tout parce que en fait des
courses à pharmacie ce n'était qu'un
prétexte
ce dont j'avais besoin c'était qu'ils me
prennent dans les bras pourquoi je vais
pas demander évidemment ça paraît pas
logique de lui crier dessus mais faut
quand même voir que c'est logique je me
suis senti démuni impuissante toute la
journée
donc il faut bien que je retrouve un
petit peu de puissance et que j'ai l'air
forte que je retrouve ma raison au moins
sur un truc donc je crie jacques grèce
je suis sous stress
c'est là qu'intervient notre technique
ils arrivent vers moi quand je déborde
et il me prend tendrement dans ses bras
et il me dit voilà voilà voilà
évidemment je le repousse
parce que ce serait trop facile
et puis je ne suis pas certaine que il
continuerait à mai mais si je n'étais
plus forte est parfaite
c'est incroyable hein quand même quand
on y pense
je la grèce où je le fuit pour qu'il
m'aime je lui dis donc
mais arrête tu vois pas que j'ai pas
autre chose à faire pis tu pense qu'à ça
je fuis parce que je ne peux plus
agressés je suis encore sous stress si
il tient cette seconde
l'ocytocine commencent à inonder mon
cerveau je me sens mieux
l'ocytocine déclenché des sensations de
bien-être de confiance d'attention à
l'autre
au bout de 20 secondes je me sens
vraiment mieux je me détends et je
pleure sur son épaule évidemment ça ne
marche pas avec tout le monde
parfois certaines personnes ne supporte
vraiment pas les bruns
ce sont celles et ceux qui lorsqu'ils
étaient enfants ont été beaucoup rejetés
par leurs propres parents
ils ont moins de récepteurs à ocytocine
ils ont les circuits de stress sur
actifs et une forte impulsivité
mais ça se répare avec de l'amour
l'amour c'est aussi très efficace avec
nos enfants
nos enfants pour appeler le lait l'amour
c'est un super bouton pour éteindre le
gaz
la prochaine fois que vous sentirez
monter le rapport de force
vous aurez une nouvelle idée à mettre en
oeuvre
je respire je reprends contact avec
l'amour que j'ai pour mon enfant et je
le prend dans les bras ou moins je le
regarde avec tendresse une ce qu'elle
leur a peut-être pas immédiatement il
aura peut-être besoin de relâcher encore
un peu de tension le plus important est
que nous soyons en lien
quand nous sommes en lien je rebranche
son cerveau je récupère le mien et je
redeviens capable dans la rue de dire
calmement la consigne dans la rue la
main et à mon compagnon d'envoyer un sms
avec un seul mot pharmacie répondre par
l'amour en situation de crise
sa demande de l'attention très vite
récompensés
ça gagne un temps fou ici on remplissait
le réservoir anti stress dès le matin
s'ils ont travaillé en amont pour qu'ils
puissent mieux faire face à leur journée
cinq minutes de tendresse chaque matin
et si ça changeait la vie ça vaut le
coup de tenter
merci